for this i and i don't have time for my  mistake you're going to let me speak  because uh here's my truth i've been  ready four times i've known women that  have been raped multiple times  gruesomely and how dare you sit up here  and try to say that women aren't worth  respect [ __ ] you  i am a woman i just became a woman it's  just like are you kidding me people  don't respect me period and i'm i mean  i'm already black so it's just like uh  yeah that already goes against me  anyways but still [ __ ]  you  living garbage ass dumpster fire  trash gum on the bottom of my shoe oh my  god i wish i had a tissue for the blood  i would mind i suggest it's your  behavior not because you're black or a  woman i'm sorry i'm sorry can i stop  here can i stop here can i stop here  please  she has just made a statement about  being assaulted which is very vulnerable  and it's very scary to do